r.
We have a voicemail line.
That number is two one nine two David P..
I'm going to admit it upfront.
This is a very ugly voicemail about George
Floyd or George, flawed, as this caller says,
just so we get out of our echo chamber.
This is an example of the perspective that
some Americans have about George Floyd.
Take a look.
Yes.
I just don't think that the public needs to
be advised that George Flawed had a long criminal
record.
He also had drugs in his system.
So, you know, what is the big deal here?
Thank you for your time.
What difference does it make whether or not
George Floyd had drugs in his system?
We have the confrontation on video.
We know what happened.
We know about eight minutes and 46 seconds
of kneeling on George Floyd's neck.
Being on drugs doesn't mean if police kill
you, it's justified.
Being on drugs doesn't mean it's justified
or that you deserve to be shot or in any other
way hurt by police.
This is very dangerous thinking and unfortunately,
it is not as rare as people like me who live
in a blue state might think.
This stuff is dangerously common.
This stuff explains how Trump still has, you
know, 39 percent approval.
Right.
So let's not forget that.
And let's make sure that we take care of business
in November, because these folks vote very,
very ugly, ugly voicemail.
We have a great bonus show coming up for you
today.
And I also want to remind you tonight we are
playing chess.
It is the second ever David Pakman show chess
tournament, 8:00 p.m. Eastern today, Tuesday,
June 16th.
I hope you'll join me.
Register for free at David Pakman dot com
slash chess.
We'll see you tonight.
Or on the bonus show or tomorrow, I guess.